I grabbed the doorknob twist it locked
shut
Plan B everyone glad babe
screamed like a little girl so ironic
I want you bros to clap for me slower
louder alright here we go
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun jump jump jump
I did not go flat tell me a story Evie
there was once a boy who died another
way ok good oh very nice down on your
knees woman first your left arm to them
like nothing up here like your fist
pumping fix fist pump know it what my
heart
Mourad moment and then 90 degrees flex
no not angry nothing you thought I was
angry
quite the contrary I fell splendid at
him my hand hurts a little bit now but
that's ok cuz I'm I'm a gentleman
gentleman never gets angry
a true gentleman keeps his calm cool and
he he he respects his environment and he
is nice to people
[ __ ] you they're like the best thing
ever there was an O bro I can brought
his paper
hey sup professor oh damn it ok tell me
a funny story you have to tell me a
funny story please tell me a funny story
no Ted
me a funny story no no tell me a story
please and don't you dare [ __ ] wink
at me
me too I'm going to hide in the closet I
don't know what's gonna happen to me but
it's at the door behind me
oh yeah I'm so pretty oh I forgot the
Rings
where are the ring hi who are you
calling gay you gay I'm not gay
it's not called being gay it's called
being fabulous go what I know the
camel's ass son of a [ __ ] my only
weakness how did you know this please
tell me a funny [ __ ] story
why should I cuz I asked you nicely
[ __ ] you asked me to get nervous
for nothing no tell me something
something no way I'm aware of an ailment
are you guys honking at each other no no
he looks odd ha ha ha you're in my way
sit down sit down boy very sure even
animals could drive
ah camera aren't you a story and you
throw it back in my face a few million
[ __ ] times for a [ __ ] story are
you [ __ ] tears with me right now
tell me the story please you are a robot
the end
final ride with my DNA i press thanks
for watching like a beverage enjoy the
sky coming bread today and i'll see you
next time to dive